in this lesson we're going to talk about
the equations of circles and how to
graph circles so go ahead and pause the
video see if you can do this particular
problem on your own and we'll go through
it together
so
they're giving us equation of a circle
right here x minus 2 squared plus y plus
3 squared equals 16. so it says find the
center and the radius of the circle and
graph the circle so go ahead and see if
you can do that on your own we'll go
through it together
so the main thing that we want to
understand for the act is the
general equation here of the circle and
you can see that h comma k that's the
center of the circle and then r is the
radius so if we look at this problem
here we can see that
r squared is 16 so we know that our
radius is four
and we can see that our center is at
positive 2 negative 3. now you can see
that these are actually the opposite
okay from the sign so it looks like it's
negative 2 here but it's actually
positive 2 and this looks like it's
positive 3 it's actually negative 3 so
just remember it's the opposite and so
here we've got the center is at 2
negative 3. so let's go ahead and plot
that point it's right about there and
the radius is 4 which means that we can
go
up 4
down 4
right 4
okay
and left 4
should be right about there and we've
got some key points there we can use
that as a guide to draw our circle
so
a very easy question to get right if you
know the formula for a circle
your center h k and then your radius you
just have to take the square root of
this quantity here to find the radius
and then graphing it's pretty easy just
go ahead and plot the center and you can
graph in the four cardinal directions
north east southwest right to find a few
other points to help you to guide your
graph of the circle so a good thing to
understand for the ect i'll see you in
the next lesson